well las vegas realtors released a
report that shows home prices still
climbing the median price of existing
single family homes here in southern
nevada was 460 thousand dollars in the
month of march now condos and town home
sales increased to 270 thousand dollars
breaking an all-time record home prices
have risen 26.7 percent since last year
as prices are rising existing home sales
are down
and as home prices continue to rise some
prospective home buyers are looking at
all the options they still want to live
in southern nevada but are moving from
los from the las vegas area to pahrump a
town in ike county about 60 miles west
of las vegas joe muller spoke to a real
estate agent there
as las vegas just continues to get more
and more expensive some people are
considering a move too per rump to get a
bigger house or even a bigger lot i
heard a paround
let's go and see how perramp is in
search of a more affordable home for um
you can get bigger lives bigger property
for less lee moore left vegas with his
six kids and fiance after looking in las
vegas for months he bought this home in
perum for a little more than 300
thousand dollars in march i just wanted
something that was going to be suitable
for my fiance and my family you know and
so we did just that it's a trend prompt
realtor leanna murphy degoody says she
is noticing more of it's almost like
california is moving to vegas and vegas
is moving to pahrump she says she is
getting a lot more calls from people
living in las vegas i'm seeing all of it
literally seeing all of it we're seeing
them retired we're seeing them commuting
we're seeing families just starting out
we're seeing everything so far this year
murphy de goody has sold 23 homes in
perramp she said the average price here
is around 315 thousand dollars in the
300 400 000 price range you're probably
going to have a home that's site built
in one of the communities that we have
out here
but you have options you can get
you can you can have an acre you can
have a half acre the single story nearly
2100 square foot home on a third of an
acre is 489 thousand dollars brand new
she says trump has more than many think
even master plan communities i know the
routes now to where i'm home a little
faster moore still commutes to las vegas
for work a drive he says is worth it for
his home the prices out here are still
affordable murphy to goody says if you
are even considering a move to prompt
the best thing you can do is to contact
a realtor who knows the area reporting
in parole joe muller live local now